what were you doing in Egypt again uh
seeing the pyramids you just went to see
them huh yeah they're dope unbelievable
it lives up to the hype yeah yeah
without it blue without a [ __ ] mind
uh yeah I mean it was to this day the
most amazing thing I've ever seen with
my eyes yeah I talk about them all the
time people be like dude you're Egyptian
like you stereotype you sit and talk
about the pyramids yeah they're so dope
yeah like if you they're worth talking
about for another thousand years now now
do you think it was the Sudanese that
made them there's a lot of theories
there's a lot of theories because which
one do you believe
I like the alien stuff personally just
because when they get into the Precision
of how on every brick is it's like it
was made in a machine yeah it's like
machines like we haven't even seen and
so that I I cried from that because
you're like yo they think aliens built
those and it's us yeah I don't know I
don't I kind of like the alien Theory I
think even if we were working with
aliens that would be profound and they
would choose the Egyptians that's what
I'm saying yeah because so it's a
win-win exactly you know what I mean
like so if we did them or failings in
them it's a win-win I mean and I say
that because you guys can work with
Israel you can work with like other
countries like everybody wants to work
with you you're not gonna go to Saudi if
you're an alien do you know what I mean
like these guys are really strict you
know what I mean they're willing to
negotiate well Egyptians we're down to
make a deal no matter what you know what
I'm saying the alien comes it doesn't
really matter like we'll we'll hang out
with aliens like Egyptian could convince
an alien I'll fix that UFO like
like an Egyptian I got a UFO guy like
back we'll make it happen UFO my phone
that's what it means to be Egyptian like
we're down like
like figure it out
we do you had a good time though people
don't understand how tourist friendly it
is yeah it's like it's really they love
someone not from there yeah they'll show
you around you have an amazing that was
the other thing that happened is that
everybody that I've ever met and maybe
this is uh I don't know but yeah
everybody ever met has like here's the
key to my home yeah like every American
Egyptian right is like you just stay in
my home when you're there I've given so
many keys out yeah yeah is it real do
you just go there and there's there's no
home what do you mean like no it's like
even my boxing coach he's Egyptian right
yeah he's like an Egyptian like champion
and uh and he's always just yeah just
stay with me and like my family yeah and
uh I'm like you're divorced he's like
it's okay
he just gives you an address he's not
there yeah and then she's like fighting
with him through you yeah
[Laughter]
he's like all right there's a drawer
stuff in there that I need you're like
dude am I I'm a mole